okay
i i i'm probably going to get destroyed
okay okay haven't read huntandi yet oh
i can't believe wait wait wait wait wait
i haven't done that
the reason why i watched it nope
okay wait i've watched it and it's
amazing yeah the only reason why i i
think the biggest takashi sim hasn't
read
so much about hunter hunter just from
outside information but i haven't
actually read it or watch it nice i own
all the volumes right now i think it's
sitting there waiting for off for a
rainy day i think it's i think it's safe
to say this it's the best show to
animate i i feel like a lot of people
say that i feel like i've been lied to
because the amount of times we talk
about hunter hunter me and connor have
just like been talking about the dark
continent i just
mean like netro getting up
i just i just always assumed that joey
was just like
literally all the information i know is
because people around me don't stop
talking about that's not okay you need
to go watch it what the [ __ ] or read it
the anime is amazing i never said i read
it or watched it
i just assumed the anime man had watched
hunter hunter
i feel like this has just been a game of
among us now we yeah
like i could probably like give you the
outline of how it goes but i don't know
what the names of the arcs i want to go
back to every clip now
i know like dark content and our camera
and arc all of those the hunter exam arc
and all that
you know
i know them again because i hear it from
everybody you have to watch it look at
this again okay i know i will love it
yeah of course yeah yeah i [ __ ] love
togashi stuff yeah you hot shot [ __ ]
holding your back what's on your mac i
don't know just
one of those i haven't started what i
want to know is how we've just found out
about this despite the fact that we've
talked about it so many times on the
podcast is this publicly known is this
widely available information yeah you've
like been a part of the conversation i
swear to god i don't know we're gonna
have to like rewind every clip where
we've talked about how to hunt i've said
it i've said it on streams multiple
times i've never read or watched it i
can't be there for the whole three hours
but yeah like again i know so much about
hunter and i know i'm going to like it
that's why i'm not in a rush to read it
or watch it because i don't know okay i
like it
me and full metal alchemist yeah it's
like it's like of course it's like we've
just found joey's full message
and again like i know it's going to be
good because i love togashi yeah
it's [ __ ] amazing i don't know
don't read it watch the anime
the animals the anime is better do you
agree
uh
yeah because i've heard both sides of
the argument listen what's the other
side of the argument the other side is
that the manga is good because togashi
is good
i mean that's
so it's so it's basically just like a
preference in medium then right pretty
much yeah i mean yeah i mean i'm
probably going to watch and read both to
be honest it's it's just a matter of
which one to do first yeah i mean
hanzonz is just prime mad house and mad
house haven't been at the prime for like
a long time i think yeah and the manga
also looks like napkin drawings a lot of
the time not in the beginning and the
volumes the volumes are fixed
they fix it yeah
in the shown and jump volumes uh the
magazines it looks like [ __ ] okay but
then he redraws it for the actual i
finished the anime and then
carried on reading and i was like am i
reading like one web comic right now
like what what is this it was about that
uh drawing honestly it's yeah but
yeah wow yeah but then he takes the time
to actually redraw everything properly
for the actual book so the books look
[ __ ] amazing making sense but also
kind of sad if you're a big hunter
hunter fan who waits and then you have
to go back and read it but yeah if you
read it if you read a week like you're
probably yeah it's like a weekly le mans
yeah
weekly yeah
um so that's your favorite shonen jump
title of course well i mean here's the
thing uh a lot of these are showing you
yeah so i kind of realized that what's
black cat doing
show black cat slam dunk each other i'm
saying jojo
oh yeah i wanna let's talk let's talk
about you hack show cause i've ever
watched i think i mentioned on the
podcast one time i tried to start it
yeah i just could i couldn't stand the
audio on the on the i don't know
you watch the anime i watched five
minutes
oh i can't take this so you hug show
it it does like uh what i like to call a
reborn basically it starts off as a
comedy ends up as an action right same
thing with dragon ball right like dragon
ball started off as a comedy and then z
came along and it became the action that
it's known for so like right
the first couple of arcs like when you
scared the main character dies like it's
kind of like a
start right yeah
it's not literally first panel you skate
our main character gets hit by a car and
dies
this was before esa car was a thing yeah
he didn't go to another world he just he
just died he just died
i know a lot about you hack a show
without ever of watching it yeah right i
know a lot of i know the bad guy i know
there's an epic fight with one guy i
don't know who it is and then
[Music]
because you know the tournament arc
right i know the tournament
he literally just described literally
every shonen anime of all time i know
the bad guy i know there's
the band now i know what the [ __ ] you
literally could have [ __ ] described
i don't know what he looks like i know
who it's going to be the giga shadow
yeah
i don't know giga chad
chad
girl
yeah i don't think he he's even the best
villain he looks like the uh you know if
you watch very odd parents
crimson chin he looks like yeah you know
like have you watched very well
fairy right yeah he looks like the
buffet from very high
looks like the buff fairy from from
fairly odd parents
oh my god he looks he looks
every time every time every time i see
the bad guy from you you hack a show i
just see that guy i'm really really
gonna do my boy takura like batman
because he has he has the muscles but
like the weird neck yeah yeah it's
literally like the fairy art parents
all right so like so have you ever seen
the anime of yuhaka show i have
not not a fan not a fan not a fan
it's i don't know it's bittersweet right
because it's like
same thing with black cat where it's
like i love the manga so much that like
it it wasn't like the perfect adaptation
that i wanted like it was good but it's
like i'd rather just reread them what
was it what was missing to make it the
perfect adaptation as someone who's like
i haven't read the manga of you hakusho
i've only seen the anime oh really yeah
oh did you like the anime i [ __ ] love
the animation you'd [ __ ] love the
manga even more okay but like is there
anything i can get from the manga that i
couldn't have already gotten from the
anime or just re-watch the animation
because i thought the anime was like a
really good adaptation especially
it's better that's solid animation you
know
i mean i don't know like i think this
might just be like the the whole thing
with like how manga art styles i feel
age better than animation in a lot of
aspects
to differ you think so like demon slayer
in the manga it just looks terrible
compared to the end well i mean that's
because like the animations the the
character designs change differently
right but like in the anime adaptation
of you hawk show they did a pretty good
job of like
re-adapting like uh takashi's art style
i feel like i haven't read it from what
i've just seen of it it looks one-to-one
to me i don't know i think sir i'll just
a glance that's like a person who's i
don't know i feel like i i sometimes
look at clips of the anime of you haksha
and i'm like something about this hasn't
aged
chinese 90s yeah it's 90s like the 90s
animation is
some of it hasn't aged very well
yeah i mean some of it's like very janky
limited animation this is like a 90s
anime but like they still had like when
during the big fights there are still
like those sakuraga moments absolutely
like those have aged wonderfully i mean
i i honestly think at this point it's
just like a personal preference like